je m'appelle Hugo j'ai 26 ans je viens
de Grenoble mais j'ai fait mes études à
Strasbourg capitale Européenne j'ai
étudié à Sciences Po Strasbourg parce
que j'avais pour objectif de faire un
master en relation européenne et en fait
ce qui m'a vraiment aidé c'est mon
engagement mon engagement associatif
d'abord là j'ai découvert le travail
d'équipe les actions de terrain la
convivialité aussi et qui c'est
poursuivi à partir 2019 dont
l'engagement militant au sein des Jeunes
Démocrates et du Mouvement Démocrate
j'ai rejoint le mouvement démocrate pour
m'engager pour l'Union européenne
les valeurs de démocratie d'humanisme
qu'on entend souvent au Mouvement
Démocrate ce déploie parfaitement vers
l'Union européenne et nous on l'a vu
pendant la campagne de 2019 quand
l'Union européenne est une chose c'est
abstraite qu'on a besoin de tout
reprendre en tant que militant quand on
veut parler d'Union européenne on doit
d'abord parler du nombre d'État avec par
exemple des gardes géantes on doit
parler de ce que fait l'Union européenne
au quotidien et ça c'est un combat que
j'aime beaucoup que je retrouve
d'ailleurs beaucoup dans les députés
européens les six députés européens et
j'ai la chance de travailler pour l'un
d'entre eux qui qui font chaque jour
vivre ma fibre militante en faisant
mieux connaître l'Union européenne et en
agissant pour les citoyens européens
donc les citoyens français je me suis
d'abord retrouvé en modem dans la
convivialité dans la solidarité
associative que j'avais vécu dans un
premier temps en fait les valeurs du
Mouvement Démocrate on les apprend
d'abord par l'expérience avant de les
apprendre dans les idées mais ensuite
ces idées ont été vivre et on les fait
vivre on se retrouve en se rassemblant
et c'est important parce que quand on
veut faire vivre des propositions nos
propositions
on doit ensemble réussir à ce qui
pourrait être le plus utile pour tous
avec le risque que ce soit par repris
mais c'est ça aussi la politique c'est
apprendre à la joie de partager des bons
moments et de d'arriver à bonnes idées
mais aussi parfois la frustration de ne
pas pouvoir les défendre aussi loin
qu'on le voudrait